[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
hold on off the [ __ ] record every oh
yeah that's a nice announcer voice so
guys what I'm just I'm just chillin I'll
tell you why Steve said sitting like
that chilling cuz he farted before we
share up that he bent down
it was disgusted by those well your old
horse you came up with that with why
would you do it why do you do this no no
I would like this no I was doing this no
no you closed it I didn't do this I'm
not saying you jump out like we're on
under amber on record I love the smell
of my own farts there it is okay I'm
sorry I'll save that under the covers oh
if I have smelly farts all day the Lord
nastier like a like a dead animal or
rotting once I save it I save it under
the covers than know like it's like now
your girlfriend is [ __ ] lucky I know
what she's she bass put up with a lot
why do you like the smell of your own
farts I don't know
I think everyone likes it we all do it
right I don't what it is it's like it's
like I can't believe I created some
discussion of you created a creator
right yeah like creating that kind of
smell that Oh like your own [ __ ] and
stuff TIFF touchy subject
no but when I when I start wrestling I
used to bite my thumbs as a nervous tic
okay
and is that where your thumb looks like
that now okay we'll talk about that
after and then I used to smell so I got
good and then I would smell your spit
breath yeah my breath and not is it
smell like poo
you know I suppose thank you yes what is
it like poo yeah your own breath well if
you put it on like skin or something
yeah look if I lick lick something and I
smell it I can smell my saliva that was
there yeah oh yeah that's not your
breath like you can smell that Pleasant
to me so I'm like it must by its might
and worse to other yeah yeah it's never
as bad as someone else smells it like
lick your wrist and then wait till it
dries and that's how your bowl that's
what you do I go like dude you kiddin
you like this like this don't smell
anything you think your teeth like this
then you go well that's the worst you
got [ __ ] that's when you get teeth
butter
mmm / its teeth butter yeah wipe it off
and you smell it that's the worst I
brush my teeth this morning you have to
go in between your teeth great
everyone has peed butter it's you gotta
get the mutter especially like after
dinner
cuz you ate three meals yeah everyone
has teeth butter throw kill take what
you try it let's do it on camera yeah go
ahead
no I have teeth you guys go ahead go get
some butter you gotta get a name no John
go to the top no I don't know it's like
I got some right now he doesn't smell I
brushed my teeth
it was fresh food you got yeah I got
some right here dude
[Laughter]
you're like that girl like [ __ ]
superstar remember yes you like their
armpits wait you guys parents do we're
like Asian or ethnic like smelly things
like my my grandpa will cut his like
toenails and then smell them oh that's
the best are you my grandpa I do that
though that's not an Asian thing dude
that's that's the nasty thing that's not
a nasty human my mom scratches her head
and then she'll be like oh I gotta wash
my hair like she doesn't wash her hair
every day and she doesn't let me look
once every three days or once a week
your Taiwanese right yeah I think it's a
Taiwanese one thing my girlfriend isn't
I'm sorry I love you but she scratches
and goes and then like walks away I'm
like what are you doing why don't you
just wash your hair like every day I
can't say no you know what though Asians
got some stinky ass [ __ ] heads
oh that's too easy I am like dude it
smells like it's like France Italy Yeah
right here only just wash my hair just
wash my hair yeah yeah right here right
here is why is it only there because
this smell bad no you smell good brother
wait right here where they trying to do
it smells like Cologne or something
yeah likes it you didn't get closer you
were scared you were scared
well you know what else does I do
sometimes well we know you're about to
say it's the the foul earwax what are
you doing babe you just smell everything
I swear
you want to get you will take away oh
that's nasty
now move your teeth butter in higher
yeah oh you know what else think
earrings
what's the Maltese Meletus [ __ ] do
you put your figure [ __ ] you put your
finger buttholes no yeah no I saw this
video [ __ ] awesome stuck her finger
up your [ __ ] so bad you're wearing
like a North Korean outfit so bad she
wore some kind of glove and it hurts so
bad why did you do that
I don't know matter why did you allow
that to happen oh it's like one of those
truth-or-dare things and I'm like yeah
try it and what did that North Korean
outfit come from I don't know I don't
remember where Oh dad like that what you
guys have that wardrobe oh yeah yeah
yeah but yeah you will like we're good
North RV that's talking about this no
but my girl has caught me taught you
what oh man no your ass why I sleep no I
sleep on this side yeah and then it'll
be really late and then I'll do this
it's just on the outer surface of your
cleanness the clothes are underneath
there's crust on it on the other its but
crusty you don't lie then I just dig
with my nails no I use baby wipes and
then I go like this and then one time
you got shipping her she looked over and
I was going yeah so she's yeah you so
much [ __ ] [ __ ] baby
I use coast I posted on I coast it up oh
look do you she's dial the head like
anti like you
yeah dial the yellow car anymore I loved
us [ __ ] life soldiers yeah
oh you look very clean though but [ __ ]
dude and you've been farting all morning
he's pretty gross but he doesn't gross
me out like Bobby does yeah oh dude my
brother's got his own can of worms oh
yeah he's the glue come on dad he puts
glue on his hand no why did he do that
he has this here a stick right jar or in
his bathroom of his just glue art pieces
of his thumb I don't know it was like a
nervous tic now like he gets like I
found it dude it was like a collection
of his own like it's only it was like in
a box er it was in a jar he sets under
fans oh he did yeah you sent them to the
fans that shit's fun though you remember
like pouring glue on your hand and in
peeling it slow it might change the
consistency of the glue Elmer's of
Elmer's I tried doing it recently with
my son's glue and I was teaching him
like look this is what I used to do when
I was little do this and then it peels
off like flakes it doesn't peel off
nicely anymore maybe they're using rice
water I don't know I said like making a
it's like making a big bubble with the
glue right and it makes this big bubble
and the outside skin kind of dries like
you know and then you would get like a
paper clip yeah poke it and you just see
it is out yeah that's true it's like a
blister yeah and then you could press it
and more of it comes off did you ever
use to get like little rice like stuck
on your shirt and then you [ __ ] ball
it up and it turns into a black ball
because your fingers are so dirty
getting your but I just told you guys
some foul stuff so I can't judge you now
some foul stuff these are fun segments
huh these aren't even segments but this
is not a second we're just listening to
all your foul yeah but the toenail wants
fun because it always smells like
Cheetos Gras cheesy did you do any
research again oh yeah what - my girls
yeah what the church smell in your ass
in church oh praise the Lord
wait so you're Catholic no I just got to
go with my girl you know I support what
she's doing yes she's Catholic shot to
my pinoys out there yeah your are
Filipinos mainly Catholic yeah dude
they're mostly kept rates so you just
went to church and yeah and then we went
to her family's they had the kids did
the Easter egg hunt thing yeah it's fine
Easter's did you do the Filipino Easter
thing no eat though we eat for sure
where'd you go
so my girlfriend we went to this one
place called radius at North Hollywood
it's like I guess born-again evangelical
church with like you know white people
with guitars with the hair looks like a
mega church it's like it's a party all
the time like people talking about this
wet rich mosaic it's like that but like
small scale oh so yeah it's like a rock
concert to get rock concert oz dope
right where I grew up more I was like
Christian Christian rock yeah that guy's
cool yeah we worship at the casino
we did yeah we were in Vegas over the
weekend to the to the dice gods you guys
had Mexican food twice yes it was fancy
mexican food called Javier makes it
fancy though it's expensive
oh that's nice it's like high-quality
ingredients but it's Mexican food like I
got aji ceviche which is like what is
straight up sashimi ceviche yeah it was
like pokey yeah and then I mean I had
the shrimp ceviche was so good and then
I got fudge itis aka fajitas but it was
like I love fajitas dude yeah that was
the first time I had luxurious like
high-class Mexican food and I was like
joking about it and everyone was like
let's just [ __ ] do this and then my
girlfriend really likes Mexican food so
she's like I want to eat there I got to
eat their souls like all right I'm gonna
go and then Steven Nikki you know Steven
Nikki yeah they had it first - it's
[ __ ] amazing so we're like old Fox so
they really sold us so good we ate it
twice it was good man they just sounds
good food huh it's so good man and all
of us won't look at money yes ma'am you
guys want like that on the slots or what
before one like $5,000 no no no I wanna
I wanna like 2221 crap so just playing
craps damn he he plays so scary they
were on fire so I started betting like
like the minimum bet would be like 10
bucks and then uh it's like you know in
your bed like you started getting like
this always rollercoaster one run and
then I was like I don't feel it anymore
so I got bad more at 24 hour 50 get
addicted and then sometimes yet
sometimes that bad up to like 300 but
I'm betting smart so sometimes I bet 300
and I'll make like 600 in just one play
Asians love gambling huh yeah I'll tell
me jokes I don't Joel I sit back crazy
to like one day we should save up money
with my 20 G's and play like $1,000
doing it Wow that'd be crazy such that
roulette though no you know not this
time you just put like a [ __ ] ton of
money on red or something gonna walk
away from the table and relay the guy's
a badass I did that last time and
the last thing you did you just walked
in worked out
I put 700 on red holy [ __ ] that's scary
I can hit red yeah and then I got 14 or
yeah 1400 yeah it's just one to one to
one so then if you get seven they pay
you seven so then you leave with 1400 so
you just dip with 14 he's like red blah
no that's better yeah yeah no before
really honest when you announce it to
everyone I was like 700 no no I did that
I was like [ __ ] this I can't leave 200
already anyway black and I was like [ __ ]
damn what have been cool if you got it
ya know this is the first trip ever that
I've ever gambled and actually came back
up like I'm never leaving like I've
never left winning ever so what are you
guys
gamble do you gamble where you're
staying or do you like go to everywhere
we walk around how does that work you
just feel the energy we walk around but
we did notice the better casinos they
you have nicer service and the deal you
get name some better consumer to
downtown and Circus Circus and stuff and
those guys are disgruntled yeah they
hate their jobs and lives yeah and if
you don't know what you're doing they
kind of like yell at you a little bit
you know what that mean what do you mean
like the etiquette like that because you
were at stratosphere that's different
know as stratosphere and Circus Circus
it's both like for this trip and then
the last trip we went to Circus Circus
those three times like those three times
that we played they were the funnest and
the dealers were so into it they're like
really ly lenient on certain things like
we're at the Monte Carlo not Russian
dudes goons they're like it's not it's
not it's still it's not like yeah on the
strip on the strip it's one of the lower
ones
I think cuz I considered it like nicer
and so they were jacket is only Monte
Carlo it's like
it's nicer than circus circus but it's
not the Arias level hmm yeah yeah
too thick middle what's the perfect
amount of time to stay in Vegas to have
a great time my finger yeah you come I
think I need to be there for a couple
weeks
yeah because I don't get to do
everything yeah so like I think over
this trip we stayed from Thursday to
Sunday but we didn't get to do
everything because we won't we still
wanted to do other things what are some
other things that you got other
restaurants there's so much other food
things to do we didn't really want
recreational stuff there's infinite
amount of things to do I want a relaxing
spa other than gambling so what I would
like to do is like a helicopter Grand
Canyon tour yeah you know like there's a
mountain top I would like to go there
like sunrise and look at like you know
the sunrise over the hotels and stuff so
like there's so many things rent ATVs
run good race cars you guys go swimming
yeah but not enough I went like one day
you rented scooters and we realize the
best no you said like Grand Canyon like
all this like this car race against egos
just go swimming get some frickin
scratches ass and smoke and no one could
see you I mean all this talk of Vegas
makes me wonder like it's Rob but what
rob a bank so you could rob like and
blow it all over there
no like oceans or something like that
it's lodged it before I went to pick
myself casinos the movie to watch like I
was all three back to back and Netflix
has all three oh yeah oh yeah yeah I
would love to just have the opportunity
to erosions 11 and 13 like let them know
like I'm gonna just let us Rob me and my
friends Rob as an experienced like a
peer you don't know when you're coming
just yeah I mean this month this month
we may show up we're going to rob and
like they want to rest this up we have
to try to rob like now just grab the
dealer's chips and run like no yeah
steep probably like the grease man right
you're flexible
that would be so genius like the fast
talk yeah yeah it's like our muscle tack
maybe let this not be what am i you know
no it'll be like pretend the siren yeah
the red dress what's not there yeah I
like it thank you I'll take it when we
got a little going so we get a rock
they'll be dope like one of the old
struggling casinos if they have that
kind of a theme I'd like Harris come
come rob us or whatever flamingo or
something that'll be ones right on the
strip Harrah's Casino yeah yeah oh don't
be so dough that's a genius idea do yeah
yeah you know there's over like a
hundred and fifty hotel casinos just in
Vegas or some [ __ ] that's a long
experience no it's fine it's fine
like the chocolate static gangster
experience like a mafia museum okay do
not wait to identity theft there though
that's why I don't like it now I
remember in Vegas yeah how did you guys
get dude like I went there cuz my
brother's performing his comedy and I
went there and then he was sick and he
was like you like by the second days
like you got to get your own room
just cuz you're sick of me being in his
room yeah so I I gave the guy in the
front my bank card to get my own room
and then I came back and when I came
back home like a month had passed and
then I was working at Jamba Juice at the
time and then I try to get money on my
lunch break to get Jamba Juice in my car
got denied and they're like you have to
call your bench yeah I bless you your
account shut down I go what and then I
called they're like yeah like you you
already took out your maximum you're at
this casino and this I'm like I haven't
been back what do you hunger mom here in
LA they're like no no you and so I had
it was a whole it was a nightmare
like I had to like get my boss to like
to to contact the B of a people to let
them know my you know my schedule all
like you've been in LA what happened is
they had some kind of card reader where
like somehow like when I gave my card or
something where it's scanned my stuff
and then they waited till I dipped
obviously in the hotel jack do you like
that
the only time you use your car I use it
at one of the eight it could've been an
ATM in that Harrah's - it could have
been a ATM either an ATM or the dude
that actually physically took my card
you know yeah
so that's why I was like I've been so
sketched out cuz it's like you know I
mean that's like always use credit cards
I don't ever use my debit that's already
linked to your money I never use my
debit ever or do you go there with money
you just take that money with you take
your cash and always use credit cards I
wish you guys would have told me that
back then yeah have you guys been
through anything like that yeah it's so
not Danny that early yeah but then thank
goodness American Express is the
[ __ ] boss because while I was
driving through Arizona they're like hey
did you make this charge right now at
Target in California and I'm like nah
I'm not even in the state homie hmm and
if they're like well we'll block it and
I was like thank you
BAM and that was it and they were like
all right and you're gonna like thanks
again they're like thank you for being a
loyal customer you're like nothing do a
mess you're like 700 on red what sir
[Music]
you